I know that it's not good but I feel
like I have no other choice but to
release those Blake Horstman posts and
delete what he says our text messages
with Kaylin Miller Keys after drama
between the pair continued to unfold
during Tuesday's bachelor in paradise
let's break it all down I made my bed
and I'm gonna sleep in it like did you
change the sheets the drama has been
non-stop since paradise began Monday
night Christina confronted Blake on
their awkward one-on-one in paradise
about sleeping with her and Kaylin back
to back at stagecoach in April and
Kaylin
finally Unleashed as soon as he got back
to the beach after telling it several
other cast mates about their tryst at
the Music Festival we talked about this
Kaylin accused Blake of calling their
hookup a mistake and claimed that he
asked her to lie about their
relationship while in paradise
to see me like are you going to hiding I
know I am be hard on everybody my life
was what I did well Blake took those
claims very seriously and shared his
side of the story
outside of paradise on Instagram after
the episode aired posting several now
deleted text messages that appeared to
be between him and Kaylin wallets
stagecoach my name being attacked like
that I feel like I have no other choice
although there were only a few
timestamps Blake labeled the screenshots
that spanned over stagecoach and one
week before the two left for paradise
from the screen grabs that appears
Kaylin was the one pursuing him at the
event in question seemingly telling
Blake to loosen up and confirming their
meetup at the festival would be quote
strictly for sex nothing more nothing
less
he calls me like two weeks ago and is
like no one can know about it the world
we've gotta live we got a lie our asses
off in paradise but it seems that both
Kailyn and Blake were struggling with
keeping their hookup a secret according
to the alleged texts one week prior to
paradise the pair seemed to have decided
on being honest about the situation for
fear they'd end up looking like liars
Blake admitted to feeling scared and
wanting to pull out of paradise
seemingly writing I guess let's just be
honest we up so bad to which she
seemingly responded everyone hooks up in
this world
Kailyn has yet to respond to Blake
releasing the alleged texts I mean
things get about as bad as they can
you